[Musique]
à
est ce qu'il est
[Applaudissements]
et oui j'ai rarement vu des proviseurs
qui faisaient ça ça serait énorme
alors comment va ma chérie comment te
dire merci
la tuque sera comme si belle allée
regarder isabelle morini-bosc dans tpm
pc ça
sa tournée survient dans l'eau
kenzy de l'équipe vous avez vu remettre
en action repoussant savait déjà mais de
visualiser de patrick sébastien oui
alors c'est génial
[Musique]
c'était au début des années 90 le
célèbre madame claude 50 20 minutes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
autrefois quand j'étais comestibles ou
plein de gens m'embête mais à l'époque
j'étais comestibles j'étais encore
comestibles
non
ouais
[Applaudissements]
isabelle vous êtes prête oui la mer four
est prête à l'aise c'est comme la
fellation ça fait mal au genou
si la paille
m
là
les harmonies base qui avait été la
meilleure élève lors de l'année dernière
lors du dernier conseil de cana et fait
maintenant on offre à tous les promesses
vous aviez été la meilleure élève donc
on va voir aujourd'hui s'il en est de
même implication il y aura que deux très
bons élèves cette semaine ce qu'on aura
jean luc lemoine qu'on aura matthieu
delormeau même a fondu et ouais alors
vous me dîtes si vous voulez je fasse un
conseil de classe ou pas c'est les
twittos ce qu'ils vont décider pour le
moment c'est à vous ça va jusque là un
peu stressé allez on y va
moi j'aimerais avoir la note de coco et
l'appréciation de couilles opus elle
peut commencer tout de suite par thierry
non non non non on rappelle que thierry
peux pas blairer is a résumé à la cause
et à moi l'idée des choses
merci négatif point fort bon moi je les
aime beaucoup
on commence par ça et j'ai beaucoup de
respect pour quelqu'un qui connaît la
télé et tous les gens qui l'ont créée
depuis le début réputé but un début et
et que oui si mal si c'est vrai mais l
air devient salée et en plus isabelle
est jeune non mais c est isabelle quand
elle regarde secret d'histoire
lcl connaît les gens dont stéphane bern
par là les inconnus et ça c'est pas
faire à m c'est vrai alors rien défaut
c'est le point faible c'est que il ya un
truc qui est extrêmement flippant sais
pas si les gens l'ont vu c'est que
parfois quand une blague a été fait 30
minutes après il ya alain blocage
c'est-à-dire qu'elle a un rire sous
forme de blocage qui ressemble à exact
et quand on est à côté des bus au départ
au début on sait pas bien ce qui se
passe on croit que donc pour tous a
réuni j'ai mis la note de 8 sur
on passe de la picardie au maroc ballet
direct moi non mais à y aller alors is
as tu sais que je t'aime tu fais un
personnage atypique tué l'inerte suis
hilarante moi tu me fait mourir de rire
et tu n'hésites pas à avoir des avis à
contre-courant de l'ensemble parfois et
comme ils sont toujours étayé c'est
extrêmement intéressant est
effectivement tu connais le métier donc
tu sais de quoi tu parles
en revanche tu fais parfois des micro
sieste pendant l'émission
ce que tu prends le train en marche et
que tu es à côté de la plaque mais c'est
aussi pour ça qu'on t'aime et puis
effectivement on l'a dit dans le magnéto
tu as une petite tendance à rades
radoter sûr quand j'étais comestibles
sur ma foi etc et en même temps c'est ce
qui fait un personnel il vaut mieux une
bonne à fait à mon mieux avec de très
basses en bois d'affaires d une bonne
affaire que tout seul serait une
mauvaise le cash-flow qu'à tous ses
points forts et ses points faibles qui
sont en fait des points forts je
t'aimerai ça va ça va
élève de la classe enfin c'était la
meilleure élève de la classe on va voir
si ça reste la meilleure élève à
benjamin castaldi
alors le le point fort on attend bien
sûr thierry moreau ps matthieu delormeau
pas le point fort c'est une connaissance
absolue la télévision ça il ya un point
commun avec drucker c'est que vous êtes
vendus et que poste ça c'est la première
chose après mois le défaut c'est un
défaut que moi je vis au quotidien
quand je suis à côté de toi c'est
n'importe quoi je t'entends pas ce que
tu dis tu vois pas très bien là tu
entends très bien aller un peu comme les
petits vieux quand elle est assise à
côté de moi elle commente tout j'espère
que ça m'empêche de me concentrer ce
qu'elle fait ah oui absolument ignobles
alors on va monter un petit truc
d'ailleurs qui s'est passé c'est que 25
ans et est à côté de jean luc ouimet et
capucine à côtés d'isabelle je les ai je
fait changer de poste et moi j'en avais
dit non non pas côtés d'isabelle voilà
donc l or il commande tout eh bien moi
aussi elle ramène tout à être la côte
est qui s'est passé quelque chose dans
le monde même si un homme qui s'est
écrasé ce sont ces ponts et ça
évidemment parfois ça a tendance à me
mois à m'agacer voilà donc en résumé
élément indispensable des missions très
drôle très cultivé malgré elle ou
parfois souvent malgré elle et pour
toutes ces bonnes raisons j'ai mis un
très beau se fait grave
capucine adav alors miles à moi c'est un
peu comme ma maman ici je suis tout à
côté d'elle donc je les adore il faut
savoir que la entre les deux là il ya
huit générations surtout j'ai une
histoire d'amour parce qu'on s'aime
beaucoup alors dans les points forts
donc très cultivé un capital sympathie
très élevé naturelle spontanée enfin
voila c'est pour ça qu'on a misé a en
revanche il ya aussi des points faibles
donc il a tu parles trop tu fais des
phrases interminables et pour des gens
comme moi bas parfois c'est pourquoi
bien trop de vocabulaire mais voilà
c'est parfois aussi perdre un petit peu
oui
autre point faible donc tu peux être
très franches mais tu peux aussi être
très langue de bois et mais je pense que
ta position à rtl c'est que battus tu
peux tu dis pas tout ce que tu penses
parce que parfois je t'entends commenter
et quand on revient sur la manitoba tu
dis pas forcément ce que tu penses mais
tu sais que je t'aime toujours et c'est
pour ça que je t'ai mis la moyenne et
j'ai mis un beau 5 et demi
est-ce qu'on cogne pour chris marquès 5l
mais que des notes pourri mais c'est
vrai attention mais encore là jean
michel isabelle c'est vrai qu'à un petit
point fort c'est ta bonne humeur
permanente serait terry reçoit mu et
mais communicatif ce qui est assez rare
voilà donc moi et j'étais en face de moi
depuis au moins cinq ans maintenant donc
ça me fait toujours marrer de te voir de
bonne humeur c'est une bonne camarade
autour du plateau et ça fait vraiment
toujours plaisir ce que même si ce kit
au monde qui t'aiment pas trop tu les
aimes en retour donc ça c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui est assez rare quand
on arrive on ça bravo tu as une très
bonne culture générale
voilà et bonne culture de la télévision
aussi donc ça c'est vraiment quelque
chose d'important dans une émission
médias le point fait le voilà c'est une
question de la discipline
ces cas là tu devrais savoir que quand
cyril part dans un délire faut laisser
parler
et voilà tu te laisses partie reviendra
vers toi et toi tu continues à parler du
sud rail mais nous devons la rive pas
comprendre pourquoi tu as toujours pas
saisi le concept et les normes et les
problèmes de tenue aussi voilà j'oublie
le fait que nous avouer un jour tu
changes et de culottes de tous les deux
ou trois jours mais c'est son coup tu
passes dans les magnétos à te curer les
oreilles ou curer le nez aux curés les
dents et qu'on a en face c'est dommage
qu'on sent très réussie surtout qu'après
vaut mieux pas qu'à vous mettre dans la
bouche
voilà donc tous pour tous ces points qui
sont quand même faible parce que ça
occupe quand même pas le temps je te
mets un koala et j'ai pas mis une belle
note qu'après la prévenue à travers des
projets mais deux c'est l'un des
meilleurs de farida voir la note et la
prestation de thierry moreau et on va
mettre le générique est juste après
thierry moreau au c1 depuis des années
voilà sandra le grand amour entre
thierry elisa ils le disent ici c'est
parti génériques et on à la nôtre
[Applaudissements]
dans le conseil de classe dit il savoure
hugues duboscq avec thierry moreau qui
va nous dire ce qu'il pensait alors
isabelle chère isabelle avait pas de
faire de compliments sur ton physique
sinon tu vas me demander de te signé
reçu ou tu ne vas me dire que tu as été
un jour comestibles je suis pas friand
de tes analyses qui soutiennent toujours
le groupe m6 où les animateurs important
je trouve que tu as un petit peu
tendance à être faibles avec les
puissants et puissante avec les faits
mais ça c'est le contraire chauffer
c'est ce que juste pour ceux qui nous
rejoignent je rappelle que thierry ne
peut pas la baie les points forts vertu
devrait enlever quelques colliers parce
que la période des sapins de noël c'est
terminé sapin de noël est là qu est ce
qu elle a elle a les boules
et si on veut savoir vraiment j'y pense
quasiment garde du manga est pour la
note ça sent le sapin
ça c'est bon il fallait la détendre un
peu c'est bon et si on veut savoir
vraiment ce qu'elle pense il faut être
une petite souris ou alors regarder les
cas tiers de jean luc lemoine donc pour
toutes ces raisons je te mets un
magnifique de la taille des très bonnes
notes ma chérie tu sais ce que c'est
elle surfe ischios le difficile de
passer après le conseilleur look moi
j'aime beaucoup et isabelle et je vais
pas parler que pour moi parce que j'ai
la chance de faire une tournée
actuellement et c'est vraiment une
peut-être la chroniqueuse la préférée de
tous les français que je la croise il me
parle toujours de isabelle vraiment et
moi au contrairement à ce que tu te
rends ici alors j'ai même jour tu aimes
aussi aujourd'hui que je voudrais dire à
chaque fois on me parle ou d'isabelle
mais on me pose la question comment des
samares isabelle et et de vous également
quand est-ce que mathieu va partir
et je vous prouver que c'est vrai c'est
moi c'est que l'autre jour il ya des
gens qui disent des choses gentilles sur
mathieu mais une fille m'a arrêté en
effet vous pourrez dire un mathieu qui
n'aime pas voilà ça au moulin mais alors
même et mathieu vous revenez tout très
souvent chroniqueurs préférés aussi je
lui ai donc à ce que dans les grosses
bottes faut le reconnaître est rare ce
qui est arrivé c'est abel est loin
devant
comme chroniqueuse très faible mais ça
ça se voit que vous une salle john
holmes en tout cas où cette fois que
c'est votre chronique aux deux prévenus
deux je trouve que moi elle est honnête
juste ans intellectuellement c'est à
dire que et dit des choses
elle n'a pas peur d'aller contre l'avis
général quand il le faut je trouve
qu'elle a de l'autodérision je pense
qu'elle a le cuir épais aussi parce que
alors je pense qu'au fond d'elle elle en
a marre qu'on la fasse passer pour
quelqu'un d'âgé alors qu'il ya des gens
dans l'équipe qui sont pas loin d'elle
en ag opus qui est drôle c'est que pour
elle en plus sans déconner c'est que ici
quand elle arrive on l'a fait passer
pour quelqu'un d'âgé faut savoir que le
matin la radio c'est la plus jeune de
l'équipe
[Applaudissements]
mais sera t elle mon frère elle quand je
t'explique quand elle arrive c'est à
taza saint-bruno ou face à kim gemini a
cédé ou pas c'est loupé la bassée
impression mais dans les points faibles
le problème c'est que de vendre en effet
une émission parallèle elle va dans
l'émission est donc notre surtout quand
elle a un scoop qui n'a rien à voir avec
ce qu'on dit elle le place en force en
force et on sait pas pourquoi on parle
de ça et aussi c'est un cauchemar pour
l'humoriste parce que si on avait que
des gens comme elle dans une salle ça
serait un drame parce que comme les
échos et si tu as une salle qui avec des
gens de fonds s'est imposé en patron un
peu plus au nord
donc pour tout ça parce que j'aime
beaucoup je dis cet ennemi
gilles verdez ja bell j'avais beaucoup
de points forts d'abord vous êtes ma
voisine et vous me supporter quand je
vous écris dans les oreilles etc
ça c'est adorable vous avez toujours de
belles anecdotes avec alain avec votre
vie vous raconter bien les histoires
franchement vous êtes drôles et puis
vous demandez toujours des nouvelles ça
c'est génial avec vous c'est que vous
demandez toujours ça va comment s'est
passé le week-end
vous êtes vraiment une personne adorable
mais au mail de vos mails écoute pas la
réponse mais attention isabelle et là
c'est une mise en garde vous dériver
lentement vers l'iceberg qui va entrer
en collision frontale avec vous à vos
points faibles sont légion il augmente
vous criez vous dissiper vous me frapper
maintenant oui je prends des coups tout
le temps comme disait benjamin qu'un cac
40 a tout le temps donc la vie ne tombe
pas autour de vous les missions non plus
fait très attention et c'est vrai que
vous aimez tout tout et tout et ça c'est
pas possible y compris et surtout ce qui
est sûr m6 donnait vraiment votre avis
il ya des nullités à la télé il ya des
nullités sur m6 il faut que vous
puissiez le dire franchement votre
vision est parfois altéré mais je vous
aime d'un amour extraordinaire et donc
c'est avec énormément de tendresse que
je vous mets d'un incroyable 3
mes parents
pour gisèle et fois c'est la moyenne
isabelle mon petit coeur crois moi je
suis celui qui te préfère dans la bande
de vente et un peu quels petits
camarades dans la loge je suis vraiment
celui qu'ils préfèrent eux mêmes
d'ailleurs a insisté longuement près de
la chaîne pour que tu qu anime une
émission en croit mais vraiment ou non
accepter j'en étais très heureux
meilleur c'est bon la fibre quoi en fait
vous allez dire que des conneries non
cyril quelle idée on l'a eue on l'a eue
ensemble on dit on s'en fout dans la rue
ensemble voilà lui c'est moi moi c'est
lui on le sait ça va être bizarre
isabelle larrouy la veille on l'a eu en
somme un allemand il n'y a qu'un seul
chef un pour moi no mercy c'est mathieu
mais quand est ce que le conseil de
classe de ce bouffon
trois athlètes australe comesa mon coeur
je t'aime énormément tes potes dans la
boue dans la boucle arrière grand mère
qu'on aurait tous aimé avoir
quand ça va pas robin maintenant mais
c'est vrai quand ça va pas tu prendras
pts et la première à m'envoyer un
télégramme mon chéri bibi mignon ça fait
plaisir ça fait plaisir
et tu bosses franchement tu bosses après
pour les points faibles je reconnais que
quand ce sont des gens que tu pas
parfois tu me dis des choses dans les
loges évidemment et aux pas tellement le
dire les animateurs que tu aimes pas du
tout et parfois n'osent pas forcément il
ya les haies et le dire franchement
donc je dirai pas ce que tu aimes pas
mais voilà parfois tu vas pas beaucoup
je reconnais que parfois les gens
n'aiment 6 passes très rare que tu aimes
pas une émission du groupe m6
extrêmement rare tu défends à l'amour
est dans le pré des terres etc
on comprend pourquoi parce que les voilà
le look dont jouit un souci t'as le look
le roumanoff
alors tant que tu n'as pas l'humour à la
limite moi j'adore un wolof fait que
même aussi j'adore elle est beaucoup
plus gros le bassin alors à très drôle
c'est une chose que je sais c'est un
compliment salvador non mais j'adore
rade alors je reprends qu elle est l où
elle est c'est plus c'est plus gothique
est aujourd'hui c'est gothique mais en
général c'est entre roumanoff et le
sapin de noël voilà il faut ôter un peu
toujours au milieu de tout ça alors
c'est ton look mais bon c'est quand même
moyen
mais malgré tout est franchement et ça
je te le dis du fond du coeur je t'aime
énormément et ses très sincères et donc
je t'ai mis notre bien parce que je veux
pas tourner rien de pareil j'étais mieux
8 mondial alors
avec la patience
la note était les spectateurs alors moi
je vais je vais donner mon avis sur
isabelle isabelle bienvenus alors oui il
donnait oui j'adore ce qu'elle sait pas
qui c'est elle a fait elle a fait comme
quand vous venez voir votre grand mère à
l'hôpital qui est un petit peu
souffrante et paix à l'âme et mamys tas
d'amis dans l'événement magnifique magin
rabier ah oui j'entraîne d'or pourquoi
et procéderont magnifique parce que sa
vie sous le nom d'un célèbre winter 19e
qu'elle veut c'est la vache qui rit
ah ouais bon tu vois la vache qui rit
aussi avait connu la veille mercier
alors oui j'avais rien préparé moi mais
je vous confirme que c'est la
chroniqueuse préféré des français
c'est aussi ma chronique je préférais
parce que je pense que c'est l'une des
autres dans la bande d'arrêt normales ou
aux yeux des gens quoi les jambes
normalité viens pas ici
non mais elle est autant elle a un avis
mesuré sur la télé et surtout on la
connaît tous elle a une carrière dans la
télé son avis il est crédible et il est
construit et pour ça je trouve que c'est
une super chroniqueuse h
c'est un des piliers de l'émission c'est
vrai que c'est un des piliers de
l'émission alors je vais donner mon avis
ionita belle isabelle
ses points forts alors ses points forts
bien sûr c'est que dès que je me
retourne vers elle dès que la lan sur
quelque chose je sais que je vais avoir
un retour extraordinaire que c'est
c'est ma petite chérie elle s'exclame
fort voilà que que c'est une vérité 1 1
voilà la mèche est vrai à check the late
for hors antenne comme à l'antenne
c'est une de mes mes petits chouchous
que c'est vraiment c'est un des plus
gros piliers de l'émission
voilà isabelle quand je constitue
l'équipe c'est une des premières que je
me voilà sur le sauce autour de la table
e
et c'est vrai qu'elle a toujours des
bonnes infos sauf cas les placements au
bon moment ces problèmes le seul petit
problème est qu isabelle voilà moi
j'adore la retrouver c'est mon bonheur
le seul petit truc c'est que parfois
elle a des très bonnes infos en loge et
qu'elle les donne pas forcément à
l'antenne parce qu'elle a peur de se
fâcher avec untel ou untel et qu'elle
est moins un peu moins incisif que dans
les loges mais on lui pardonne ce qui
est tellement mais tellement drôle que
voilà on veut qu'elle soit juste drôle
en fait dans l'émission isabelle c'est
pour ça que je lui mets 1,8
red appelés tweets hausse 6,7 c'est
moyenne générale 6,3 sur d'isabelle
métier carrière valérie bella il valait
1 pas voir le classement s'il vous plaît
direct derrière merci on va voir le
classement très vite mais et c'est
valérie bénaïm qui est la première de la
classe projet et oui alors un roman il
ya une chose que thierry habib qui
m'était vraiment faussé qui correspond
pas mon caractère et l'a dit elle est
forte avec les faibles et faible avec
les forts m'appelle je sais exactement
la verse
j'ai tendance à être beaucoup plus on a
compris l'ovaire abbaoui cantat et jean
michel pardon je suis je t'adore et tout
mais il vaut mieux que je sois présente
dans les moments où il ya des gens qui
tu attaques par rapport au csa que que
sur les cultures les babioles là entre
nous voilà c'est tout alors j'ai rien
compris
[Applaudissements]